george soros vient tout juste d'avoir 14
ans gagnant l'année dernière d'un
important tournoi aux états unis il
s'est qualifié pour le championnat
mondial des adolescents qui aura lieu en
caroline du nord à la fin juillet laurie
paradis 18 ans vient d'obtenir une
bourse pour aller étudier et jouer au
golf avec l'université fresno state en
californie compte en commun ces deux
adolescents ils sont passés par toutes
les étapes du développement golfique
québécois et joue aujourd'hui tous les
deux la normale georges fl parcours au
complet ça veut dire de l'initiation
il y quand jour les techniques de
supervision il ya commencé à jouer au
golf je pense qu'il a commencé avant de
marcher trois quatre ans quand j'ai
commencé à jouer puisque cette [ __ ] j
j'ai pensé à le prendre comme xfr laurie
a aussi la piqûre dès le départ à 8 ans
son inscription con quand jours en
compagnie de sa soeur aînée à donner une
trajectoire bien spéciale à sa vie on a
voulu faire toutes les six semaines
elle a commencé du début avec la
formation des camions après ça le ferait
pas grand espoir le programme relève au
mirage à la fête au programme
perfectionnement dernier graphe implanté
il ya une vingtaine d'années via le
programme sport études
le golf est maintenant enseignée dans 14
écoles à une centaine d'étudiants du
secondaire
le sport est restée d'un bras gamme qui
évolue vers l'excellence donc quand ils
sont pris en charge durant l'hiver ce
durant le printemps et automne et
ensuite son suivant compétition n'était
fait que donc sont encadrés le
pratiquement 12 mois par année puisqu à
la qualité des entraîneurs a également
un grand rôle à jouer dans
l'amélioration des jeunes golfeurs du
québec
leur formation est plus poussée
qu'auparavant et à leur permet de tirer
les jeunes vers le haut
c'est vraiment alexis dumas bonjour à
s'améliorer
ont frappé toutes les après midi l'hiver
c'est dès midi à crozon les pistaient
dinars afin qu'un paquet entier beaucoup
évidemment tous les intervenants du
milieu sont d'accord l'enfant doit avant
tout s'amuser et les parents doivent les
laisser jouer sans leur imposer de
pression monte en mai toujours dit que
la journée que jamais c'est ce que je
veux vraiment même si je regrette pas
mon choix pitt en amont à auch
je suis pote points d'eau je voudrais
pas continuer à jouer
mais il ya des temps que tu sois
concentré pic du toit voir en pratique
que des tant que mode faut jouer avec
des amis on essaie d'organiser la frappe
de balle oui mais tout shopping du potin
et puis organiser des analyses vidéo
mais je terminais toujours les
entraînements la dernière demi heure
lorsque sont fatigués ne peut organiser
des jeux intéressants brezault forme de
compétition en intérieur avec les autres
pour susciter l'intérêt
si il part un petit peu l'intérêt sans
nécessairement dit qu'on veut pas le
pousser faut l'écouter d'un foyer pour
un jeune vaduz présent peu dijon fait
plus pire vient 14 15 puis performe gg
gibus ou c'est pas parce qu'on arrête à
13 ans que notre carrière est terminée à
leur niveau georges lory joue beaucoup
de tournois depuis des années souvent
aux états unis pour les parents les
dépenses sont donc très élevé grand 35 m
par année là et incluant les voyages les
sports études l'encadrement les balles
l'équipement mais on parle de l'ailette
ce n'est donc pas à la portée de toutes
les familles celle de george sur josh de
se priver un peu messari veulent voyager
ma mère aussi
mais ils disent ok on va arrêter puis
lui vaut faire des tournois wpt
du côté des paradis le fardeau financier
sera bientôt allégée puisque comme sa
soeur audrey avant elle
laurie ira vivre le rêve universitaire
américain quels conseils donnerais tu l
as une jeune golfeuse qui commence à
jouer du golf compétitif et directs
étaient en compétition
qui est un trou qui va faire comme
thibault s'est pas y aller parce que moi
je me suis dit
tu vas aller tourner quand j'étais jeune
qui remonte jusqu'à la fin du monde bien
mon dieu ma carrière de golf est
terminée parce que j aimerais être on
essaie vraiment fait pour être mais j'ai
pas tout le temps bien joué j'ai pas eu
tout le temps des bonnes saisons qui
chante l'hymne moi ce que je voulais
être en ce moment s'inquiète faut pas
s'accrocher au détail
michel chabot radio canada montréal